I was like I'm gonna die I'm literally
gonna die here you ever have an itch you
can't scratch or fractures to both of
your arms but still have to act because
it's your job maybe not as common for us
but for these MCU actors they were
barely able to make it through these
scenes number one it had to have been
serious if someone went to the hospital
right as you'll see a little later on
this video the MCU must have a great
relationship with hospitals with
production of black panther wakanda
forever underway Leticia Wright was
rushed to the hospital for an injury she
wasn't in the hospital long but she got
a fractured shoulder and a concussion
from a motorcycle scene so that's pretty
serious and this entry left her going to
therapy long after filming ended I'm
still processing it I'm still working
through it in therapy it was really
traumatic number two this would be the
most annoying thing ever props to Paul
Bettany you know that super cool video
of Paul in the makeup chair getting
ready as Vision it looked awesome to us
but he was not so eager to put all those
Prosthetics on it was so uncomfortable
for the fact that he could not reach
that annoying scratch he wanted to itch
there's one place on my body that I can
scratch and that's my nose so anything
else is impossible plus my hands are
purple so I get everything purple number
three Andy Circus was not ready for
Chadwick boseman's commitment to the
character t'challa a somewhat
straightforward fight scene in Black
Panther ended up being a bad and painful
experience for Andy very first take he
made me so hard in the chest because he
couldn't really see with his Moscow he
admits he was an honest a game for this
one but just wasn't expecting Chadwick
to be so perfect with the moves I felt
like he broke my ribs in that very first
take after taking a lovely knee to the
chest and probably many more injuries
they all in all ended up shooting the
fight scene 30 times number four
Sebastian Stan was lucky enough to not
get injured too badly during stunt
sequences but for one without any stunts
he twists his ankle for the Falcon in
the Winter Soldier in the boat scene
Sebastian jumped onto the boat and got a
gnarly ankle twist this wasn't about to
stop him from filming the scene however
so he came up with a little trick to
push through like I actually couldn't
walk on it in between the takes when we
had to do the setups I would run
upstairs and two people would help me
out up this boot and I would just take
my foot and put it in a bucket of ice
number five when you're a big actor it
can be really hard to get you small
again when Paul Rudd was a little man
running through the school in Ant-Man
and the WASP it quite literally took
forever to film that scene that was
incredibly difficult and it took a long
time to film it seemed so simple as an
effect but they had to delicately
rehearse his movements plus make sure
all of the camera angles matched up we
had to mix different size props because
Angeline and I are both in the scene at
the same time Paul recalls a very
lengthy shoot for this little scene and
is still shocked at how they were able
to pull that off the war work that went
into that sequence was mighty impressive
number six Baby Groot is the only one
who can pull off a boogie session in
front of a one-eyed monster this one's
not about baby Groot since Vin Diesel
was in a comfy Booth all day no this
one's about the actors in the background
these actors dealt with three things a
fake monster fight choreography and a
fake Groot it took them a long time to
match each character's eyes correctly
with Groot but also make sure they knew
where the monster was as they were
juggling moves The Man Behind this magic
cinematographer Henry Bram broke down
what the actors went through we know
exactly where Baby Groot is in the frame
and we know where the focus needs to be
and we know the timing of how Dave has
got to be thrown to the floor number
seven Robert Downey Jr had so many hard
scenes as Iron Man and breaking ankles
was just a normal thing I broke my echo
once but then that gave us time to do
some more script Provisions for Iron Man
3 in particular in the big fight scene
at the doc RDJ had to jump from one
platform to another what follows next
came as no surprise to him as it was
just another ankle break it looked
horrifying to the casting crew but he
pushed himself to his limit and kept the
scene going number eight how do you
shoot Arrows with no arms just embody
Jeremy Renner of course Jeremy fractured
both of his arms on the job and was
dealing with therapy during end game he
just didn't want to let anyone down so
he powered through it what else do you
do you just stop and cry and everyone go
home he wasn't going to let his injury
get the best of him and he was still
going to remain in high comedic Spirits
I'd be like sorry guys I'm not going to
use a bow and arrow now in Avengers so I
have to kind of push through so that you
can perform for everyone number nine we
never thought this would ever be said
but Brie Larson really preferred hard
stunts over scenes with cats to be fair
it wasn't like she didn't like them she
was just extremely allergic to them so
when Captain Marvel began filming the
production team changed their minds real
quick when Larson would pull them aside
constantly for them to switch to CGI it
became this joke because the crew would
watch me all day doing crazy stunts but
then the cat showed up on set now was
like we need to have a plan we need to
have a conversation number 10 the most
unexpected of injuries come from the
most unusual spell castings this was the
case for Elizabeth Olsen when she paled
her arms about his Wanda she apparently
went in a little too aggressively and
injured her shoulder it seemed like
Olson was the odd man out for a certain
scene she was casting spells in as
Jeremy Renner explains she got an injury
in her shoulder everyone else is doing
Dives and rolls and all this stuff and
she's doing this hand movement and goes
oh my God my shoulder number 11 from
actor to knife master Sebastian Stan
really suffered to pull this scene off
when taking on Captain America and
Winter Soldier Bucky's an expert with
knife play and he keep in mind you can't
really see GI this so Stan spent months
perfecting knife flips and tricks walk
around the house for a while just sort
of flipping this plastic knife driving
in intersections and just flipping in
the car he also rehearsed with Chris
Evans and stuntmen to make sure he
wasn't whacking anyone in the face with
a plastic knife number 12. stunned
people are actors too and Bobby Holland
Hanton deserves a lot of respect for
playing both Captain America and Thor's
stunt doubles his hardest scene was an
Ultron when cap surfs on the highway on
a car door even for an experienced stunt
performer this was a whole new world
Hanton explains it was a new experience
for me I had not done much outside of
the vehicle work with live roads and
live traffic I had to really be focused
in on top of my game and make sure
everything for me was in place number 13
RDJ really hated filming those heads up
display scenes in his helmet for someone
who likes acting with a scene partner
Robert was not pleased to be spending
time in front of a black screen and
saying his lines to the air would he
prefer this over broken ankles now we
honestly don't even know anymore but the
way he puts it they're just screaming
Direction at you it's like irritation
therapy number 14 this superhero Landing
was both awkward and painful for the god
of thunder in Avengers Chris Hemsworth
recounted on the scene where he kidnaps
Loki as Thor jumps down and executes a
Nifty little superhero Landing it looked
kind of awesome but behind the scenes
was a whole different story it was not
as elegant as one would imagine I had to
come down and land on the cliff step and
have the conversation for the first
couple of ticks I just face planted into
the dirt it was incredibly ungraceful
and unsuperhero-like number 15. wow they
really had RDJ building an actual Arc
Reactor well not really but production
actually had Robert's soldering on
pieces in a cave for Iron Man this was
not only dangerous for the actor but it
must have been incredibly difficult to
get right luckily our Tony Stark had a
little expert help behind the scenes
prop Master Russell Bobbitt explains I
taught him how wiring Works he soldered
and we had these extreme close-up shots
and it really defined Iron Man in that
moment oh how happy we are to not
actually get beaten up while filming a
superhero movie good thing these actors
made it out unscathed for the most part
was there a scene for you in particular
that you just would have said oh heck no
two let us know in the comments
[Music]